Цілий день працювати в масці на заводі нелегко,
але Ольга Лизун рада, що принаймні не втратила роботу.
45-річна монтажерка радіоелектронної апаратури
щодня перевіряє 4500 автомобільних динаміків.
У подальшому ці прилади стануть частиною сигналізації
для автомобілів європейських брендів, серед яких - низка німецьких.
Під час карантину через CОVID-19 мукачівський завод "Точприлад" не працював,
тож Ольга, як і решта робітників, хвилювалася, чи відкриється підприємство взагалі.
Вона - єдина в родині, хто нині має роботу.
Для мене дуже важлива.
Не знаю як для кого, для мене дуже важливо.
Я одна працюю, бо чоловіка скоротили, і він
уже 6 місяців ніде не працює. Я одна працюю.
Дочка в декреті, теж з цього заводу. Важкий час, звичайно.
Ми сподіваємося, що буде ліпше.
Ользі пощастило, після карантину її не скоротили, на відміну від 25 її колег.
Звільнити цілу зміну цеху радіоелектронної апаратури на підприємстві "Точприлад"
довелося через різке зменшення замовлень із Європи.
Є персонал, який працює тут дуже давно, і, звісно, важко,
що люди втрачають роботу. І люди вже навчені, спеціалісти.
Всю зміну скоротили, потужність зменшилася…
Виробництво аудіодинаміків - ніби й не першочергової деталі для автомобілів, -
напряму залежить від попиту на нові авто. А він
у зв'язку з коронавірусом та економічною кризою різко впав.
Так, Німецьке об'єднання автомобільної індустрії  порахувало,
що кількість замовлень на нові авто у ФРН навесні впали на 70%,
а з-за кордону - майже на 50.
Прогнозується річне скорочення виробництва автомобілів на понад 20%.
Отже, зменшаться замовлення і для українських підприємств,
які напряму чи через інші компанії співпрацюють із німецьким автопромом.
Обсяги від наших замовників впали від 20 до 40%.
Є домовленості, що дещо повернеться, а решта не впевнені.
Пішли деякі групи під скорочення.
Але ми тримаємо контакт із людьми, щоб повернути їх.
І з замовниками теж у контакті.
Ситуація змінюється не те що щотижня, а з дня на день.
Ми сподіваємося, що всіх людей, яких скоротили, ми повернемо.
Така ситуація доволі типова. Німецько-японськоа компанія в Україні (Sumitomo Electric Bordnetze)
повідомила, що з 7 тисяч робітників після карантину на роботу вийшли лише 1400.
Зараз їхня кількість збільшилася до 5 тисяч працівників.
За прогнозами кінцевого клієнта компанії,
падіння продажу автомобілів очікується на рівні 40%.
Для підприємства це означає скорочення штату.
Чимало заводів, які виготовляють автокомпоненти,
розташовані в сільській місцевості або у невеликих містах,
тож люди втрачають чи не єдине можливе в регіоні робоче місце.
І якщо в Німеччині від масових скорочень в автопромі рятувала державна політика
- там працівників просто перевели на скорочений графік роботи - курцарбайт -
і держава продовжує платити їм щонайменше 60% зарплатні,
то в Україні підприємствам довелося викручуватися самим.
Деякі поблажки були від держави стосовно податків, і ми це розуміємо.
Але дуже великий плюс - держава не робила перепони для бізнесу, і ми за це вдячні.
Якщо не допомагаєте, то принамйні не зважайте.
У березні одне з полегшень було несплата податку на землю і на нерухомість.
Я б не сказав, що дуже, але допомогло.
На думку Александера Маркуса, голови правління
Німецько-української промислово-торговельної палати,
в нинішніх умовах виграють ті українські підприємства, які орієнтуються на електрокари.
Попит на ці машини в Німеччині може зрости на тлі державних премій
за купівлю такого екологічного авто.
Він також звернувся з листом до українського прем'єр-міністра Дениса Шмигаля
та повідомив про загрозу скорочення робочих місць на підприємствах
з виробництва автокомпонентів в Україні. За підрахунками палати,
в галузі задіяно понад 35 тисяч працівників.
Відповідь від Кабміну була короткою: для підприємств
із кількістю співробітників понад 250 осіб допомоги не буде.
Ні, я не був задоволений відповіддю, тому що йдеться
про підтримку лише малого і середнього бізнесу. А підприємства, де працює понад 250 чоловік,
не мають жодної чи, точніше, майже жодної підтримки і, на мою думку, це погана політика.
Ідеться не про гроші від держави, а про гнучкіші приписи і регулювання. І це найважливіше.
У семи виробничих цехах підприємства "Точприлад"
працює близько 700 працівників, тому тут замість державної підтримки
шукають інші шляхи виходу з кризи. Наприклад,
розвивають мережу замовників, аби не залежати лише від автопрому.
Це не так просто, адже нині 90% продукції виготовляють саме для автопрому.
Ми вдома сиділи на карантині, але завод нам оплачував.
Робота важлива, бо дома сидіти без грошей погано.
Робота потрібна.
Такої довгої відпустки у мене ще не було,
це було вперше.
Найбільше, що я пам'ятаю до цього моменту,
це коли знаменитий вулкан в Ісландії мав виверження
і тоді були затримки з поставкою сировини. Але такої довгої точно не було.
Та наразі, кажуть, важливо зберегти потужності, які є,
не підвести замовників, а отже, не допустити поширення коронавірусу на заводі.
Перевірка температури, носіння масок та регулярна обробка рук
ще надовго буде нормою для мукачівських робітників.